oh
hello
here hi
you guys hear me yeah we can hear you
loud and clear
awesome hey Pearl hi
uh is it Sarah Sarah don't worry you can
sorry you can speak to purple I think
you're here for Pearl right now I think
it's fair for you oh yeah
yeah
um I just wanted to say that
I get a little
what's it called the Reverb
okay oh anyway
um maybe turn your to maybe turn the
actual video down
turn the video down and just speak to us
without the video volume that might help
oh
okay I'll just try my best here so I
just want to say um I I really like what
you're doing Pearl um I want you to
understand that there are certain
beliefs that I have that
make me think that you're fighting an
uphill battle that is going to be
overwhelming for you eventually this is
why I say this
so
when you look at the root word of sodomy
you know you know what it is it's
actually something that came from the
Bible
well here's the thing behind that
there's a lot of corruption a lot of
what we are seeing right now that is
kind of like the upbringing
like the whole transgenderism lesbian
gays and all that stuff
that is something that is going to be
even more pronounced eventually in the
future where it's going to be
all accepted eventually
well
history shows and archaeologists have
confirmed that there was an actual
couple City Sodom and Gomorrah that were
actually destroyed how were they
destroyed they were destroyed by
Brimstone and sulfur
well there is no other place in this
world that you can find that and so the
archaeologists pointed to the Bible and
said okay
something caused these things to come
down well they just don't magically
appear I do believe in God and I do
believe that in the historical event
that God did that well why did he do
that
well because this world became so
corrupted well I'm sorry that those
cities came became so corrupted that
um sexual immorality you're talking
about
um
uh you know the whole lesbian thing in
in transgender and whatnot
um
the marriage out of I'm sorry not
marriage just uh sex out of wedlock and
stuff like that things like that
um and he got to a point of like
even bestiality and stuff like that so
he burnt all that down that place is
uninhabitable
this world is gonna end that way and
that's why I'm saying you're fighting an
uphill battle because you're going to
see a lot of this thing going
uh it's going to be overwhelming and
stuff like that but I'm really glad what
you're doing because
um us guys we need uh a voice to speak
for us that is not from guys that's from
a from a girl's perspective you know and
and that's why I'm glad that that you're
doing what you're doing
um I have been married to someone that I
didn't know was with another woman prior
to and that was something that I should
have you know prodded
prior to my marrying her but I didn't do
that
um it lasted 10 years and after that she
requested the divorce or she asked for
the divorce we got divorced and stuff
like we had a a a a little girl so I
decided you know I'm not going I'm gonna
go down can I can I ask you a question
can I ask you a question abroad can I
ask you a question oh yeah go ahead go
ahead yeah did you when your wife filed
for divorce did she divorce you to go
and be with another woman or did she
divorce you to come be with another man
it took me to be another woman
wow wow
yes so and now my daughter's having
issues
so what do you what do you think is in
the future you think that like they're
gonna burn all the cities down like what
what are you for correct
yes so what happens is
there's this thing called the image of
God which we are the image of God
and the opposite of that would be Satan
so Satan is trying to take the image
away from God
and so what is the image of God he
created the marriage
so the marriage has been treating two
people and that's the Covenant right
there
so what do you do now you separate that
you Empower one that is not supposed to
be empowered which is the woman because
the man is supposed to be the leader
so can I ask a question so you see you
see your your your your lady left you
for another woman
um
did you at any point in time during that
relationship did you know that she was
that way inclined so she was 100 totally
heterosexual with you
after about five or six years
she let me know of her deepest darkest
secret which was at
interesting okay
um
wow you know it was a little difficult
um
but then
it
made it it makes it easier for me to
Let It Go and to find closure
how are you doing how are you doing
after the divorce
I found my lady
that I'm currently married now but I'm
married are you married again you're
married again yes I am okay I I found
her abroad
where where did you find that possible
bro
[Laughter]
that's right okay so I'm trying I'm
petitioning Iran to get over here let me
let me let me ask you a question because
people always talk about the possible
Bros and people going abroad you know to
find a woman what she was she a younger
woman was she a child
because this is what people say they say
that you know people are going abroad to
find very younger women who are
impressionable
he's actually five years younger than me
I'm 43. oh okay well she's over eight
yeah okay you said you're married she's
not here yet
she's not here yet no oh okay
hang on whoa whoa whoa what happened so
you married over there
no I married online
well this just got interesting how the
hell do you marry online bro like what
the hell is that
so there is this uh gentleman that was
finally on YouTube he is actually
Filipino he married his wife as well
this was during the pandemic
so then this company from Utah
they do online marriages and they're
actually
um legitimate because the board the
What's called the um my bro my bro have
you seen this woman have you met her in
real life
uh yes I went over there for a month in
April okay so you met you met her for a
month and then you got married online
and how we got married before I met her
wow okay
so you you married a woman before you
met
before I met her physically yes
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible